AN UTTER FAIL:
$7.6 billion, 7,800 jobs,
and 3 years of time. This is how much Microsoft
lost on their worst acquisition of all time:
Nokia. From an outside perspective, this was
an obvious disaster just waiting to happen.
Microsoft had taken a gamble with a legacy phone
maker that was struggling to keep up with the
modern world of smartphones. And unfortunately for
Microsoft, things didn’t play out in their favor.
But what if I told you that there was more to this
story than just a misguided acquisition with a
bunch of money. You see, the bleak state of Nokia
isn’t just obvious in hindsight. It was obvious in
real time as well. In fact, investors were largely
against the acquisition. The day that the deal was
finalized, Microsoft shares fell 6% losing the
company $15 billion in market value or over twice
the price of Nokia. Why you ask? Well, the writing
was already on the wall for Nokia. Not only was
their market share and brand presence collapsing
but they had lost $4 billion the previous year.
So Microsoft was having to massively subsidize
their operations just to own the company. Hearing
this, you’re probably thinking that Microsoft
must’ve been real desperate to get into the
phone market, and you’re right, they were
real desparate but what if I told you that
there was more to this story. What if I told
you that Microsoft was actually blackmailed
into buying Nokia? Nothing straight up illegal
went down but Nokia very much leveraged their
position and power over Microsoft within
the phone market to force a $7.2 billion
deal down their throats. So, join me as
we take a look at how one of the biggest
companies in the world got blackmailed into
making the worst acquisition of their life.
A DESPERATE PLUNGE:
Taking a look back, Microsoft’s foray into the
smartphone industry can actually be traced all
the way back to early 2004 to a project
name Photon. The goal of Photon was to
create a mobile version of Windows that would
be launched by the end of 2007. To be honest,
Photon didn’t look all that great but contrary to
popular belief Microsoft was very much ahead of
the curve with smartphones. The problem though was
that they didn’t stay ahead of the curve. Photon
ended up being one of those projects that kept
being delayed time after time because frankly,
Photon was just a side project for Microsoft
that they didn’t really care about. That was
until 2007 when Apple would reveal the iPhone. On
the outside, Microsoft would put up a brave front
and act like they didn’t care about the iPhone. In
fact, Steve Ballmer, the CEO of Microsoft at the
time would actually laugh the iPhone and claim
that it didn’t appeal to business customers.
But while Microsoft acted like they didn’t care
for PR purposes, internally, they were scrambling.
They would reorganize their entire mobile team
and start working on a “new operating system”.
This was basically code for putting lipstick
on Photon and shipping it as the next big thing
but this itself took way longer than expected. In
fact, they would end up rushing a beta version of
this in 2009 dubbed Windows Mobile 6.5. Microsoft
was very much hoping that the Windows name would
carry this product but that simply wasn’t enough.
Users would see right through this crappy software
and even Steven Ballmer would end up admitting
that they screwed up. You would think that this
failure would lead to Microsoft reevaluating
their position and approaching the smartphone
market from a different approach but Microsoft
simply doubled down. You see, Microsoft very much
had tunnel vision. All they could see was that
Apple and Google already had solid products on
the market while they didn’t. So, their number one
goal was to just to get onto the market as soon
as possible and unfortunately, this led to yet
another crappy launch with Windows Phone 7. During
the announcement, Microsoft would proudly tell the
world that they had struck deals with many of the
world’s largest manufacturers including Dell,
Garmin, Asus, HTC, HP, LG, Samsung, Sony, and
Toshiba. Microsoft was so confident in the Windows
Phone 7 that they would actually stage a funeral
for the iPhone. But when the Windows Phone 7
actually made it to the market, it was clear that
Microsoft had cut a lot corners. The phone didn’t
support copy pasting, custom ringtones, tethering,
multi tasking or even traditional notifications.
Microsoft didn’t think they needed notifications
because of their cool little windows tiles but
the public didn’t agree and they weren’t the
only ones. After seeing how Windows Phone 7 turned
out, half of Microsoft’s hardware partners would
back out of their deal. And honestly, I think only
reason they other half moved forward was to stay
on good terms with Microsoft but this wasn’t
enough to cover for Microsoft’s shortcomings.
To make things worse, developer support for
Windows phones was atrocious. Developers
would usually just start with iOS then move
onto Android and then just skip Windows. And
given that 3rd party apps make the smartphone
experience for most people, a lack of 3rd party
apps made the Windows Phone an absolute no go.
If this was anyone else, this right here is where
their journey within the smartphone market
would’ve come to an end. But, since we’re
talking about Microsoft, they would have the
money and resources to throw a last hail mary.
A HAIL MARY:
Given the topic of the video, I’m sure you guessed
that Nokia was the hail mary but this actually
played out a lot differently than you might think.
You see, Microsoft didn’t just move to buy Nokia
immediately. They didn’t really want to own Nokia,
they just wanted a rock solid partnership and as
such, they would send a trojan horse to Nokia in
late 2010 in the form of Stephen Elop. Elop was
the president of Microsoft’s business division
which at the time was producing record profits,
so he was in a pretty comfortable position. But
for some reason, in September of 2010, Elop would
take a job offer from Nokia to become their CEO.
From the very beginning, this deal seemed fishy.
Why would the leader of the largest division of
the largest software company in the world leave
to join a dying giant? And as for Nokia, Elop
was their first non finnish CEO in their 145 year
history and to give Elop this job, they had fire
a man who had been with the company for 30 years.
Surely, there was more to the story than just
Stephen being a good candidate. Was Microsoft
and Nokia secretly planning a partnership to take
on Google and Apple? Well yes, that’s exactly
what they were planning. Just a couple months
after Stephen became CEO, they would publicly
announce that Nokia was going to exclusively sell
Windows Phones. Nokia was betting it all. Instead
going down the proven path of selling Androids,
Nokia had chosen to take a gamble with Windows
but their allegiance to Microsoft went much deeper
than just running Windows. Nokia would basically
become a subsidiary of Micrososft supporting
everything Microsoft. For example, they would
choose to integrate Bing instead of Google, they
would integrate Bing Maps instead of Google Maps,
and they would ditch their own app store in favor
of the Windows Phone Store. They basically became
the go to Windows phone maker and they were
decently rewarded for it. Unit sales would
rocket to nearly 10 million per quarter but in the
grand scheme of things, this was still a massive
step down for the phone giant that was Nokia. In
fact, calling it a step down was an understatement
as Nokia was getting obliterated. During, Elop’s
tenure, Nokia’s stock price crashed 62%, their
mobile phone market share haved, their smartphone
market share fell from 33% to 3%, and the company
lost €4.9 billion. Likely the best evidence of
just how bad things were was this leaked memo
from Elop. Elop would compare Nokia to a burning
oil platform and claim that Nokia had to jump into
the icy water to have any chance at survival. This
metaphorical jump was partnering with Microsoft
and going all in on the Windows Phone but this
wasn’t quite playing out as expected. What Nokia
needed was a savior, and who better to save them
than Microsoft. Nokia had bet it all with Windows
so it was only fair that Micorosft returned
the favor and bet it all with Nokia. But,
while that sounded nice on paper, Elop knew that
he needed something more than just good faith to
get Microsoft to buy into a growing money pit.
And with that began the bid to sell off Nokia.
BLACKMAILED:
Elop didn’t just jump straight into threatening
Microsoft. Rather it’s likely that he started off
with a Motorola sort of approach. If you didn’t
know, around this same time, Google would acquire
Motorola for a ridiculous $12.5 billion. On paper,
this was a terrible deal as Google would end up
losing billions on this purchase but that’s just
on paper. The reality is that Google actually
gained something invaluable from Motorola: their
over 20,000 granted and pending patents. It’s a
really long story and I have a full video about
it but essentially Google would use these patents
to save Android from litigation from Apple and
Microsoft. Seeing this, Elop likely thought about
pulling the same thing over on Microsoft given
that Nokia had way more patents. Over 90,000
patents to be precise. But there was one
fatal flaw with this strategy. Microsoft
wasn’t desperate to save themselves from a lawsuit
like Google was. I mean, they were literally the
ones that were suing Google with patents that they
already had, so it was back to the drawing board.
And that’s when Elop realized that while he may
not be able to bribe Microsoft into buying Nokia,
he could force their hand. You see, as Nokia
became the go to Windows phone manufacturer,
other manufacturers had slowly stepped away.
In fact, by 2013, Nokia controlled 90% of the
Windows phone market. So, why not threaten to move
to Android? And that’s exactly how things played
out. In early 2013, Nokia would publicly announce
that they were considering a move to Android. To
be honest, this was an easy out for Microsoft.
They could’ve just let Nokia move to Android,
accept that they had already lost the smartphone
wars, and move on with their lives. But instead,
Microsoft would freak out that they were about to
lose their last chance to win smartphones and they
would end up prematurely buying Nokia’s phone
business for $7.2 billion. This was honestly a
genius move by Elop as he would brilliantly make
his way back to Microsoft as an executive after
having a terrible run at Nokia. In fact, Elop is
still at Microsoft serving as their executive vice
president. So, looks like things played out pretty
well for Elop but the same could not be said for
Microsoft or Nokia’s phone business. You see, just
a couple months after Microsoft acquired Nokia,
Microsoft would get a new CEO: Satya Nadella. From
day one, Satya saw Nokia for exactly what it was:
a desperate attempt by Steve Ballmer to salvage
an already lost industry. So instead of focusing
his efforts on Windows Phones, Satya would
focus on the Azure and enterprise side of
Microsoft. And once he had enough results to show
shareholders from that side of Microsoft he would
ruthelssly incinerate Microsoft’s phone business.
He would sell off the remaining parts of Nokia,
lay off thousands of Nokia employees, and
write off $7.6 billion in losses. Keep in mind,
they only paid $7.2 billion for the business
so they essentially wrote off the entire amount
and another $400 million on top of that.
Yeah I don’t think it’s controversial to
say that this was by far Microsoft's worst
acquisition and its all because they let
the threat of Nokia switching to Android get to
their head. Unlike Microsoft’s bet with Nokia,
Google’s bet with Motorola may be their best bet
of all time. Check out this video to learn more.